[Music]
my son
is
starting to become somewhat of an issue
from a behavioral standpoint due to his
mom essentially no longer playing any
sort of active role in his life where is
mom mom is currently in
a mental health facility outside of
philadelphia yikes man
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
deloney show so glad that you're hanging
out with us
hope your life's too well
i was gonna say i hope the gas prices
have come down but they won't have and
so hope we are getting through that
together and
figuring out bread and diapers and
formula just a mess it's a mess out
there
and um when things get messy remember
lean into the messy lean into the
generosity not
i got to get mine and i know that's so
hard to do so hard to do just practice
it try it practice it and try it
so hey we got a packed show today and um
i got some heads up on what's coming and
so there's a lot on the show so i'm
gonna go straight to the phones and not
do a couple of minutes of cringy preach
pre-call talk here so let's go to
lawrence
in philadelphia what's up brother
lawrence
uh hey doc how you doing i'm good my man
how are you
well have kind of a rough season going
on right now appreciate you uh
taking your time to speak with me oh you
got it anytime so what's up my brother
so i'm a single dad and i've had uh both
kids essentially full time since october
of 2018. my
my daughter turns nine on saturday and
my son is 11.
my son
is
starting to become somewhat of an issue
from a behavioral standpoint he
is struggling with life right now he's
full of tons of anxiety and frustration
due to his mom essentially no longer
playing any sort of active role in his
life which i completely understand where
is mom
mom is currently in
a mental health facility outside of
philadelphia yikes man how long was it
degenerative how long was that going on
well you know she
she
when i met her
i knew that she was regularly taking
opioids because she was in a car
accident in college when a tree fell on
our car and she suffered from chronic
migraines back in the early 2000s what
the best neurologist would do is they
would just toss a whole bunch of
narcotics at you that's right just just
to manage the pain and when you know the
affected narcotics took off
at that point in time they would switch
the dosage or the brand or whatever case
it was and unfortunately she became
hooked
i don't blame her for that
it's unfortunate and you know i i was
somewhat ignorant to what narcotics
could do to someone because back when
you and i are growing up john they
didn't really
refer to any type of opioid pandemic and
i just didn't know what the symptoms of
addiction were with respect to something
that brilliant doctors prescribed and
was readily available at pharmacies
right um i'm so sorry that's that that
i've i've seen that up close that'll
take your take everything i'm so sorry
man
yeah it's it's it's unfortunate you know
it ultimately changed everything
in our lives it tore our family apart
there was
there were certain things that went on
which just forced me to unfortunately
file for divorce which
i never saw myself doing but here we are
other things started happening at which
point
got my lure involved and
we filed for
residential custody and they've been
living with me ever since and
since august of 2021 they've seen her in
person like an hour and a half
and was she in was she institutionalized
when they saw her no she wasn't
she wasn't she was living with
their sister's father at the time they
have a sister that's going to be three
they've seen her maybe a handful of
times
since she's been born because of issues
with her mother yeah um it's it's just
it's really frustrating and it's
you know it's it's a lot of things it's
a lot on me but
you know i'm doing my best just to give
the kids as regular of a life as
possible under their circumstances so um
first thing do this for me okay take as
deep breath as you possibly can and hold
it for a second
hold it
no you let it out it's cheater i did
take it
try again
you can edit this out nope we're leaving
it in
hold it
all right let it out
and then i want you to drop your
shoulders down as hard as you can pull
them down okay
sure i can feel you talking about this
and starting to speed up your cadence
because this is still really this is
you're it's just not as though this is a
healing wound this is a this thing's
still bleeding right the cut's still
happening right
it's daily yeah all right um
did was she taken when she was pregnant
she she was we were had her monitor
monitored by um a a different doctor
that essentially weaned her down to a
smaller dose but she was still taking um
during with pregnancies um did your kid
either one of your kids or your son
especially um was he diagnosed with
nails
uh
neonatal opioid withdrawal syndrome
he wasn't diagnosed with it shortly
after he was born he was put in the nicu
just for monitoring um they were worried
about that they didn't do any of that
with my daughter
okay all right so the she said your wife
wasn't on methadone or any other
she was not a method no okay so they
just were just cutting her dose okay
um all right so i wanna be real careful
about something and hopefully this gives
you some peace even though it's gonna
feel like it's gonna make things more
chaotic okay
i want you to do your best you can from
this point forward for the rest of your
kid's life
of not saying because of or due to
okay
um earlier on when you're talking about
your son's anxiety he's got this anxiety
because he it's
because he can't see mom
he probably has that anxiety for a whole
cocktail of reasons okay
and whenever we dump
we distill it down to a single
single problematic data point we try to
solve that data point and it never makes
the whole thing better and so i want to
look at the whole ecosystem that's going
on here okay
um there are a and you probably know
these but this is just for the audience
as much as it is for you
um
the
longitudinal neurodevelopment literature
is all over the place and so one of the
first things i do is i take animal
models and i move them out and when you
do that there's just not a ton of stuff
out there
um some of them show um
opioid use in utero
effects of things like iq and language
development all that kind of stuff some
of them show no development no
difference some of them showed
difference for up until like four or
five months some of them show difference
in boys and girls almost all of them
universally um this is with methadone so
i think it's methadone maybe it's the
other one
um shows some sort of increased risk for
anxiety for adhd and all that so
that's cool
to know that
um here's where i think a lot of those
studies miss and it's i don't blame the
studies because they're just trying to
to set a baseline biochemically
but your kids have grown up in a world
of chaos is that right
unfortunately yep hey don't do that to
yourself okay it just is it's it is okay
let me give you that it is unfortunate
but i don't want you to take ownership
of the misfortune at this point okay
um
they grew up with a mom as an addict
and for a kid you know this but that's
so
um dysregulating to see a human in front
of you
and touch them but they're not really
there you know what i mean
luckily at the time they're so young
that i don't think they realize that
well i'm telling you their bodies for
sure did 1 000 did they absorbed it the
same disconnect you felt relationally
where you could be holding hands with
somebody that you knew was not there you
could sleep with somebody have sex with
somebody and they're not there
they pick that same thing up and it's
it's exponentially works worse because
they're have neuronal development going
on right then okay
and so what what i am most compelled by
is gabor mate and others who have looked
at
pre-maternal stress in utero stress in
moms creates this downstream of this
this cocktail that pulses through these
kids
and they end up with anxiety and all
sorts of cascaded things down the road
why do i tell you that
the thing that you can control right now
is the
ecosystem the peace right and that's
that is where i want you to focus your
energy on moving forward
um so i just gave you a lot of
info and i didn't even let you ask your
question so what is your question
question
um
the behavioral issues are starting to be
something beyond my control okay tell me
about it i'm starting to become
just
talking back hitting kids biting kids
like what are we talking about here he
yeah i mean he's been he's been
suspended a time or two due to physical
issues
um there was a time he
started you know throwing hands at a
sitter i've called the police on him on
occasion because i didn't want to
hurt him while restraining him and he
was just someone out of control um i in
terms of discipline you know i i do my
i have a hard time not yelling at times
just because there's there's seems to be
nothing else to do
at that time i haven't write sentences
sentences was the latest thing i've been
doing in terms of discipline and he
absolutely hates that but lately when i
say right census he will just say no no
i'm not going to do that yeah and and
you know all this stuff combined the
issues at school
his therapist is saying we want to get
him psychoanalyzed his family crisis
counselor at school wants to get him
psychoanalyzed you know law enforcement
has spoken to him and they say you know
he definitely needs some type of
psychiatric evaluation and i'm just i'm
worried yeah
he's going to put on meds yeah because i
know what he did to his mom yeah
yeah
and your your
fears is um valid okay
let me talk let me talk to you about a
couple of of things until we get to the
psychoanalytic part okay um or the
psychoanalysis psychoanalytics
um
so i want you to start thinking about
that body that little boy's body how old
is he you said
he's 11 11 okay
fifth grade fifth grade so you have a
little boy whose body is being
overwhelmed by
the sensations and feelings and that
comes out with behaviors that in adults
are criminal acts
in children it's simply symptomatic of a
body that is um think of a cup
underneath a faucet it's just
overflowing okay
and throwing hands
punching swinging yelling just that
caustic screaming is a body that's
dysregulated and this is going to sound
counterintuitive but that's a body
screaming for connection in a in a
backwards chaotic way
and so it's a body screaming for
boundaries in a chaotic way and
yet there's a disregulation for when you
put boundaries down now he's like no i'm
not doing that and so i want you to
begin to think of punishment not as a
way to force him to do things he doesn't
like or are uncomfortable with him
can would you be willing to flip the
whole paradigm around for me
i'm going to try anything though okay i
want you just to try this for 30 days
and if it's a bust write me back and i
promise i'll read the email aloud um on
the show that i've i failed you okay
okay
um here's what i want you to do
uh let me ask you one question have you
ever sat down with him and just talked
about mom how heartbroke breaking it is
for everybody
yes they are very difficult
conversations how do they how do they go
i mean
as of late it's trying to understand
it's trying to tell him why he can't see
mom currently
you know to try to express why there's
mom's mind is sick
um
you know
every time he sees him she looks normal
and you know her voice sounds normal
having a kid comprehending that their
brain is sick and making them do things
or not do things that they should be
doing that's that's very difficult
concept
and then nothing like there's no way for
him even to talk to her that's a hard
thing you know
if we've done the thing you know it's
almost like you know she's dead it's the
same thing yes except she's not and
that's the problem there's no closure
right no no it's just she's not there
and you know he has a hard time thinking
you know well daddy you know you did
this where he keep me from mommy so i
have him call
my ex his mom you know she'll confirm
everything you know i keep telling him
how much i love him yeah okay so i want
you to this is not at this point about
data this is about his body okay
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to address the body here here's a
couple ways we're going to do that
number one we're going to if you don't
already invite him into this don't force
him the whole world's been forced upon
him okay so i want you to invite him in
to
and again i got a 12 year old and i know
this is awkward okay and even my son's
like dad and just tell him
this one's for your old man even though
i know it's for him
is a
20 to 30 second hug a couple of times a
day maybe right before school and after
school and say we're gonna do hug time
and he may go dude i'm not doing that
see if you can get him to buy into that
okay and your daughter too
cool
the second thing is i want you to find
ways
highly intentionally intentional ways
not accidental ways to put your hand on
his skin
preferably on his face or on the back of
his neck okay
and when you're hugging him i want you
to put one hand on the back of his neck
and hold that area 20 to 30 seconds two
or three times a day okay there's a ton
of bioregulatory sensory stuff that
happens skin to skin trans transmission
and it's gonna bring his heart rate down
it's gonna bring his body down okay and
all we're trying to do is teach him what
it feels like to not be spun up
and we're going to teach him that in the
presence of dad and in the presence of
relationship is where you find that
spinning slow down
and right now everything about
relationships spins that sucker up you
see what i'm saying
it's you these are quiet teaching
moments that i'm stunned or not in every
psychiatric office in the world
um i would even go as far to say
something as silly as um
oh man
um
some sort of hey let me massage your
fingers
let me like we hold a lot of tension in
our hands a lot of tension in our
feet um
with little children little little kids
who have been abused one of the things
that a a therapist might do is take a
lotion and just rub feet because all
we're doing is teaching the body how to
be touched and how to
okay so that's number one number two
have you all done any sort of letter
writing to mom
no i tried to get him to write in a
journal just to capture his thoughts and
he just he's even hesitant to doing that
okay
um two things to do there number one um
get a journal that is between you two
and tell them hey this is two secret
guys just for two dudes
and you write to him and leave it on his
bed
and all he he has to bring it back and
put it on your bed hopefully it's got
one line in it and in that journal i
want you to do age-appropriate stuff
but let him know that you miss mom let
him know that today was a hard day or
today was a good day or today i actually
cried and what we're teaching him is
dad's not crazy and he's not crazy
and so his feelings start to look like
dads because right now you look like a
big strong tough
got it all together guy and we want to
teach him no here's what's going on in
dad's heart and he can read it over and
over and over again okay and hopefully
he begins to share with you i've heard
parents write me back and say my kid
just wrote today was good
and if they start weeping with they
didn't they've never had that level of
connection okay um another one is write
letters to mom and it'd be cool if you
all did this together
and his letters may be short and you can
tell them you can be really angry
you can be really sad i want you to tell
her about what happened today
but we're gonna write these things and
we're gonna put them in an envelope and
you are not gonna mail them
okay
but this is an exercise and you can
commit to doing it too
sure
we're teaching him here's where those
feelings that are burning holes in us
here's where they go here's a good place
to do that is to write it down okay
and then
here's the last one and then we'll get
to the medication stuff the last one is
i want you to create with him and your
daughter
i know this has been a mess i know this
is all hard i miss mommy y'all miss
mommy but here's the world we're in
right now mommy's in the hospital and
she's not okay right now and so we need
to create some rules for our house and
you've probably heard me talk about this
on the show multiple times it works
really well here
and what we're doing is we're going to
go to like michael's we're going to go
to a hardware store and get a big piece
of board or whatever we're going to doll
it up and make it nice
and we're going to write the lawrence
let's say your last name smith the smith
family rules this is who the smiths are
and they're less rules but they're more
value so let's call it that the smith
values
and i want your kids especially your son
but your daughter to
for them to have input on this
who are we and i want you all to make it
a fun exercise get ice cream and
whatever their favorite food is make it
a fun thing where y'all are writing
things down and then you're gonna paint
it on this board and you're gonna hang
it up in the living room even if it
doesn't match
here's where we're getting at
when your son hits somebody
you do you are not punishing him
he is choosing to go meet with the
police
and what we're slowly going to do is
teach him
that he has a choice in how his day goes
not that he's going to do something that
will that will
cut off relationship because right now
he knows he can push you far enough
that his punishment is disassociation
with dad that you will use your
relationship with him as a weapon
you did this you have to go out here i'm
casting you away from me
and i want to flip that on its head and
i want him to understand that when i do
this i'm choosing to leave dad and i
don't like to do that
because right now he's trying to see
how far i can push you before you're
going to go to
how far can i push my teacher before she
disappears on me like mom did
and what we want to do is teach him any
disappearing is going to be a choice
that you're making and dude it breaks
this is how i tell my kids these are my
exact words
it breaks my heart that
i'm choosing to have my heart broken
right now
that you chose to leave the room for 30
minutes or for an hour or to not go
fishing with us
i'm choosing to be sad about that
because i only like fishing when you're
with me
and you just chose to do xyz not study
for this test to not whatever and you
chose to not go and i can't stand that
please don't make that choice ever again
because i don't like fishing without you
you see our flip and now i'm telling you
it's a light switch night and day in my
home okay because they feel the strong
sense of ownership about it now like all
of us sometimes it's like
yeah it's worth it i'm gonna drive 70
over the speed limit if i get caught i
get caught right but most of the time
i'm watching this thing shift okay now
let's get to the meds
i do believe that your kid is in in line
for some sort of psycho eval
okay sure
as a parent i cannot speak to as a
psychiatrist so i'm just going to tell
you
you and i are hanging out on uh
grabbing a drink and you and i just met
and we're just hanging out okay this is
what i would tell you
about what i would do with my kids
um
i feel hyper
strong about benzodiazepines
as a no-no okay i have it written into
my psychiatric power of attorney that if
i get institutionalized they still can't
give me those drugs i'd rather be
institutionalized than be on those drugs
and out into the world okay
so i have a very
strong um and that's off of ana limke's
work in any number of psychiatrists who
are now beginning to write more and more
about this ongoing benzo crisis that we
got
i will also say that there are some
ssris that are
magic
for dealing with anxiety
there are do you mind just elaborating
what the the benzo myopine and ssri are
it's a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor right so
there are two different medications that
have two different brain chemistry
pathways
um one basically keeps the it's just the
way that the synapses the neurons talk
to each other across synapse and ssris
are gonna be traditional stuff like
prozac right and it simply keeps more
stuff hanging around benzos are the
xanaxes of the world and it's a it's a
rabbit hole okay
and so
i have i would have no problem
if i sat down with somebody and they
said all right we've done all the stuff
your son um
at this point he's so dis-regulated his
alarm system is so sensitive right now
like dude you've been in a you've been
in a hotel where you have you're
steaming up the shower you know and
it sets off the fire alarm the smoke
alarm that's just an attitude
it's a it's a it's a dysfunctional alarm
system your 11 year old may be there and
that's okay
what an ssri is going to do is going to
help turn that alarm down a little bit
it will not solve the problem but what
it will allow him to do is to then go
sit with a counselor
to then begin to regulate some of these
um behaviors that you and i was talking
about a minute ago and
be very open with the doctors about
mom's
opioid addiction
about the prenatal use of opioids
and your concerns about addictive
behaviors and any good psychiatrist will
walk alongside you in that journey tell
them that you want to try any and all
behavioral interventions before you get
medication okay but i do think
a psycho evals is important right now
okay that doesn't mean they're going to
take your kid from you and dope them up
for eternity you're still the parent
okay
now that's my concern if you sit with
the doctor and they say look
you talked to some nut job on a podcast
who said stay away from benzos we think
this is the best thing for you right now
you can say great i'm gonna go get a
second opinion and go get a second
opinion and tell that psychiatrist
exactly what happened i went in saying i
if we have to do meds let's do ssris
they forced benzos do you agree with
that and dude they're the doctors and
i'm not
and so at some point you have to decide
i'm going to go off into the woods and
treat this on my own or i'm going to
listen to the doctors and i also know
that you've got a
you got burned bad by them in the past
you lost the love of your life and all
she did was whatever the doctors told
her right
that's right that's right and so this is
a scary season right now so all i'm
telling you is how i would approach this
if these were my kids i cannot give you
medical advice and i can't give you even
therapeutic advice because i don't have
that sort of relationship with you or
your kid
but i'm just telling you what i would do
if it was my kid
ultimately i think your kid needs some
professional intervention and i also
absolutely understand your um
discomfort with that it's well earned
i'm just also worried that my daughter
might ultimately hit down the same path
i i think i think it i think there's a
every reason to believe that here's the
deal some kids respond by punching kids
other kids respond with straight a's
often young young girls will exhibit
adhd and anxiety by getting really quiet
and following all the rules
and so we don't know what's going on
inside of them because we're just
looking for the demonstrative behaviors
they're gonna either violate to violate
whatever rules we have or they're gonna
cause uh further chaos and so yes i
would expect growing up in the home of
an addict with a mother who used um
while she was in utero and all of the
relational chaos and the divorce i would
expect there to be challenges with your
daughter as well that's why getting
upstream
with
dad connection with skin-to-skin contact
with hey
i'm teaching you a choice looks like i'm
teaching you what the gap between
stimulus and response looks like all of
those things are gonna create a new
household and so going all the way back
to the very first thing i told you
we're not looking for well it's because
mom left because here's the natural
tendency is then i'm gonna find somebody
to replace mom and that's not how that
works
um what we need to do is we need to
change the entire air in that home
and let me tell you one last thing
you my friend have got to do some
healing work on your own is that fair
yes yeah
your son and i don't say this in a
shaming way i say this in an empowering
way
is absorbing your tension in chaos too
okay and so one of the greatest gifts
you could give him is for you to go see
somebody and begin getting well yourself
is that fair
that is fair okay
um you will also set a give him a
picture of what a
grown man who's going to get help looks
like and that would be one of the
greatest gifts you can give him one long
term
okay
yes
so
please go see a psychiatrist or go see a
professional okay it's expensive to get
an eval very very expensive
um
and if you get a good one it can be
worth its weight in gold
and it will give a road map to you and
do not hesitate to speak up and also um
don't hesitate to get a second opinion
if you're uncomfortable okay
okay is that fair
something's gotta change
there you go i'm just you know i don't i
don't wanna lose my kids that's right
they're great little people um
in the same if you will introduce the
the choice language that i was talking
about in your home
um instead of yelling and by the way
from this call on we're not yell anymore
cool
i've been working on that i know i know
but let's don't work on it anymore let's
just say no more and here's what we're
gonna do
you're gonna introduce choice to your
kids very very soon
like this weekend probably
and
when you're about to blow
i want you to look at your son or your
daughter and say i'm choosing to step
away for a minute so that i can be in
control of my body
and then i want you to step away for a
minute and go walk around the house and
then you come back and you're teaching
your son you're giving him a picture of
what
regulating your body looks like
regulating your emotions looks like what
then when that hurt and
fire come up
how to release it because those punches
he's throwing that's just his version of
you yelling
it's it's that's that overrun of emotion
right and so i want you to lead the
charge in your home on showing what this
looks like and that also means you got
to get some counseling asap brother will
you do that
yes
i i did a little bit but i i clearly
have work to do
i want you to go into a counselor and
say i want to heal and be well i don't
just want to talk endlessly for the next
nine months i want to learn to heal and
be well
okay and let's start there okay there's
gonna be a lot of action not a lot
there's gonna be some talking for sure
it's gonna be a lot of action a lot of
changing your behaviors okay i want you
to stay on the line i'm gonna send you a
copy of my new book own your past change
your future here's the deal
at some point you're going to sit down
you're going to own what happened
your whole world blew up your wife got
sick and your whole world blew up
and then you have to be about what are
we going to do next okay so hang on the
line here we're going to send it to you
do you commit to going to see somebody
yourself and taking your kid to see
somebody i don't hear you say it
i'm gonna
heal myself to make my kids better nope
you're gonna heal yourself because
you're because you're worth being loved
my man
okay hey you didn't fail your wife dude
stop carrying that around
you did not fail her
i hear you the medical system did
she struggled a whole she and she
probably has a whole lineage you got to
set that down man this isn't on you you
didn't fail
did you drop pills in her drinks
clearly not okay well
some of the calls i get on the show
aren't so clear you didn't fail
so you're not going to get well for your
kids you're going to get well for you
because you deserve
to be well
and by doing that
they're going to have a chance to be
well too
they're lucky to have you my man and
starting today everything is different
everything's different
um hang on the line here we're gonna
issue this stuff and if you would like
um we can clip this call for you raw and
send it to you so that you don't have to
wait a month before this thing launches
and have some of that info so we'll see
if we can get that to you the next
couple days head on the line here and
everybody else we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care
we spend time energy money on everyone
else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
it won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours
today dr john deloney show listeners get
10 percent off their first month so
decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to lacey
in iowa what's up lacey
hey how's it going we're partying how
about you
um
trying to do the same a little bit at a
time
very cool what's up
so in the great words of whitney houston
i want to feel the heat with somebody in
particular
somebody my husband
oh i want to dance with somebody hey
listen this is amazing but uh i went to
this incredible uh
uh heavy metal concert theater like this
this hardcore show and that was the
intro song like all the lights go down
and that's the song they played and i
smiled from ear to ear and thought this
show's gonna be incredible and the fact
that you just brought that up is just
perfect so good for you all right let's
get back into it okay so you want a
party husband's not so down tell me more
i would say my husband wants to try to
be down to the party but
um we've been together for about nine
ten years five of those married
and
we have tried
every avenue imaginable
to not only like increase the
romance dating life but also the
intimacy realm
and i have particular preferences that
are probably not safe to say on uh
public
podcasts but yeah they are
in particular hold on
you
remember back in middle school when
somebody would like be like hey
lacie
um i know someone who likes you and uh
i'm never gonna tell you and they just
leave
you can't do that you can't call and be
like i've got this crazy thing and then
everybody every listen number one
nobody's listening to this show we all
know that right um and number two
you can't just drop that so what what is
your
thing
uh my sexual um
tendencies are more risque into the
abbreviations of bdsm
and
i i have always had that interest and
i've learned to dial back to meet my
husband's needs because he has never had
any other sexual partners aside from me
and he only had one other long-term
relationship before me and that was just
in high school so
um he has spent the last you know nine
ten years learning with me how to do the
things that i need and would like
and in turn you know i do the things
that he enjoys and likes however
in in very plain terms i mean he's
always vanilla he likes his same old
same old and he's just a sappy heartfelt
guy that's he's just a big cuddler and
i'm
i'm really the opposite of that i'm like
every touch of the skin could
it just sets my soul on fire and i'm
like what's coming next i'm just alive
and ready for more
and with him it doesn't really go any
more than that so
i guess we're just rolling around in
like the same routines and we have been
for a long time and it got pretty bad
about a year and a half ago
we had
you know just kind of came to the
conclusion that beyond therapy and
medications and all kinds of
session treatments that we just weren't
compatible in that realm and it really
hurt my heart because i love the
daylights out of this guy and he loves
me endlessly and we didn't want to call
it quits just because you know we
weren't
romantically connected in the same ways
and we just felt like we were living
like like roommates almost you know like
come home do the tours do your
day-to-day job and you know chat about
your day and that was it
so we're just trying to find
a new way to make
us compatible in that way and i don't
know if that sounds weird to say out
loud but no not wrong i'm just i'm stuck
i don't i don't know what else to do
that would get him to want to
participate in the ways that i need both
in the dating world and in the intimacy
realm
so i'm not living that same old
regurgitated vanilla lifestyle that i'm
just not so in love with
you're so descriptive and it's beautiful
the regurgitated vanilla that's the kind
of sex that everybody likes is
regurgitated vanilla
god almighty
um okay so
man there's so much here i i
you and i could talk for a couple hours
um and you're a joy to talk to so number
one thank you um
being into what you're into with your
husband i i i really
don't want you to
you're coming at this with a specter of
shame or a specter of weird and maybe
it's just you're just trying to be
respectful of this show and stuff like
that so um there's nothing that i say
that every time i say nothing i'm always
surprised um
very few things surprise me when a
couple gets together and like like hey
we've been we've been married for five
years or nine years and
i this is kind of what does it for me
everybody's different the challenge like
you mentioned is how do i say this out
loud how do i let my needs be
spoken into being and how do i let
somebody hear them and then how do we
figure out what comes next right that's
the hard part and so i like to think of
intimacy as just about closing the gap
reaching across whatever
you know gap of discomfort there is and
saying this is me this is all of me are
you still in right
right what i hear you conflating
is romance
intimacy
and
sexual preference
and i think
when you conflate the three of those
three things like that they all they all
are linked but when you conflate all
three of them you find yourself in a
position where you can never be happy
you see what i'm saying
yeah every single thing is sexually
charged with you is that right
you said every time like he can walk by
you in the kitchen and just put his hand
on your hip as he's trying to get around
you and you're like it's on now is that
right yes yeah
okay
um and
he can also not do that and you begin to
wonder what's wrong is that fair or no
yes
okay where does that stem from
um i have a medical condition called
polycystic ovarian syndrome and part of
that comes from
um in a
bad balance of hormones i shouldn't say
bad but it's just very abnormal um and
so i have the testosterone of two men
yeah don't ever ever ever
this is just your this is just how you
roll
yeah yes it's different it's different
than most women i know so they they're
like this is you you want what yeah well
the spectrum of people listening you
know i can imagine there's a cluster of
men going what what this exists right so
i get that and
then right but there's also reality to
it too right
yes which is hard
um
okay my husband and i have had very
cordial conversations about it
and very like
deep conversations so much so that i
explain i've showed pictures and videos
we've you know we've gone through the
whole gamut of you know different means
of therapy and talking things out so i'm
not ashamed to talk about it i'm not
embarrassed or anything like that even
to friends and family who are honest and
really want to know so i mean he knows
exactly exactly what i'm looking for but
it's just hard for him to have that
desire to do those things because it's
just not in his nature he's just a lover
he's not like a
hard and heavy person like i'm even i'm
looking forward hard and heavy people
don't always like being hit
or
the one that i've heard over time is
they don't feel comfortable
hitting somebody out you know what i
mean so it's it's both yeah right
and
um
so here's the hard question how old are
you
i'm going to be 30 in a year in less
than a year here's the hard hard
question
are you going to leave them
i don't want to no no no because i know
the last couple years you've had this
thought you wouldn't be calling me
are you gonna leave him
no okay
here's why that answer the answer to
that is very very important because then
it reframes how much work we're gonna do
how we're gonna re re-um imagine this
conversation because right now this is
about a particular sex act that you want
that he won't do or let's be honest like
with if you're fully down the bdsm
rabbit hole it's a context and it's an
environment that you like
right and it is
a particular um
power hierarchy right whether it's a sub
or a there's a whole lineage here right
right and yep it's a whole context and
so if you are all in on this person
and together y'all do not create this
context what you have to be willing to
do is to say okay how do i get
a
super charged libido
how do i get my idle crave
contact
and i crave um
what i would call an increased heart
rate is that fair
yep like i if it's not and by the way
you know that how this thing rolls right
it just increases because i got to keep
pushing that boundary right
so
how do i
create an environment where we do that
on terms that don't also isolate
my husband
and so we're not trying to figure out
ways that he can
dress up and things that make him feel
uncomfortable not trying to figure out
ways that he can
um
hit me or be hit in ways that make him
freak out that's not what we're trying
to do sure we're not trying to
accomplish this particular sec what
we're trying to do is find new
environments
the masterpiece is the book come as you
are by emily nagotsky have you read that
book no but i've heard you mention it
many times so i'm eager to read it
here's why that book is so important i
think both of y'all need to read it
together here's why that book is
important
you think of this in terms of sex strife
and you have a high when he has a low
one is that fair
yes what she did for me was reframe the
entire thing and sex isn't about drive
at all it's environmental it's all it's
ecological in a way it's it is
how do i create a world where there's as
few offs as possible and a few ons as
possible and what that does with
somebody with a particular sexual fetish
is it begins to let them stop focusing
on that object or that thing or that
this one singular environment and begin
to look at a bigger picture
okay i'm trying to think of um
this is somebody who gets amped up in
the only way
they just in high school um they were a
weightlifter on the football team and so
they're 48 now and all they can do is
lift weights and all of a sudden both
shoulders blow out and they go to rehab
and stuff but they can't lift heavy like
they used to and that that their body
still needs that release
and so they learn
how to get that release cycling or
wrestling or rowing or any number of
other things that's what we're doing
here not because inherently the thing's
wrong but inherently
that particular environment makes your
husband feel less than or um
scared or frightened or whatever and you
love him too much to do that
is that fair
so are you willing to consider
alternative environments
yes that still includes asked for those
okay as well and i think those that
definitely makes him uncomfortable
because in his like you know vanilla
nature
where he's comfortable is
exactly where he's comfortable not that
loose performance function outside of
that area but
you know it takes a lot longer to build
up the
energy and the
the rush to get going in a place outside
of norm so yes so he's gonna have to
also reimagine this thing too
and be willing to lean in and say okay
this particular actions in this
particular environment i can't get there
i've tried i can't get there
can we figure out other ways
that at this moment or like what
can we just cuddle have boring married
person sex can we just do that right
it may be that um
there is some sort of uh we're gonna
create a um
deck of cards and we're gonna put a
particular act on it and we're just
gonna draw out of a deck and my heart
rate will get up hoping that it's this
one and his heart rate will get up
hoping it's um that we're gonna lay here
and watch the office whatever the thing
is but we're going to do these things
together that are going to create a
context that our heart rates are going
to get up and that you're going to get
the skin to skin and the um
the
if i i'm trying to say words that
instantly roll into like sound like sex
acts words but that's not what i mean
but i mean the visceral response right
that your body craves okay right um
this is less about hey we need to go
find some new videos and this is more
about i want you guys to reimagine the
whole spectrum here so do me this favor
number one know that you're not broken
and he isn't either
number two this isn't about trying to
dial up his sex drive or dial yours back
number three
bdsm is a proxy
for
an environment that gets you skin to
skin contact that makes you able to put
your head in a different psychological
place that gets a um that is rough and
that gets your body moving in a
different way right so where can we
create can we set that proxy aside for a
second and begin to create a new
environment where we still get those
things but everybody's okay and i know
you're thinking dude i've had this
conversation with him a million times
i want you all to read this book
together
and begin to say okay
um maybe it's
we go
once a month we go get a hotel room
somewhere and it looks like this or
maybe like i said we have five things in
an envelope and we draw one out once a
week and we no matter what's going on we
do that thing
or
maybe it's
different parts of the house or in the
car in the garage like any number of
places and things you can do or you can
go
let's begin thinking outside the box and
what you're going to do is not close
your box you're going to begin to
look at
other options and he's going to begin to
expand his
and you are going to look at this as a
series of breaks and gas pedals
how can i turn more of the ons on
and more of the offs off
a couple of exercises that dr nigoski
has in the book is
let's get beneath the
fetish and say what are the things here
that are turning you on
let's do a step let's be real clear
let's write them down what are the
things he gets by cuddling and closeness
and
as you say regurgitated vanilla how do
y'all get to those places
write those things down and let's start
to look for overlap here and say okay oh
we can both meet in the middle here in
the middle here what if we tried this
and what if we tried this and then we're
gonna have post-mortem which is not
super fun but we're learning new things
and here's the big word we're practicing
new ways of being intimate with one
another and remember intimacy is not
about
how we have sex intimacy is
i'm bridging the gap
of discomfort
i'm willing to bridge that gap do you
see me
and do you still love what you see
and that's hard and we often i find it
really my own relationship all
relationships
that's a recurring
question a recurring thing do you see me
and do you still love me
lacey you're awesome i've got the
highest hopes for your marriage please
let me know i want you to read through
this book let me know how um the
homework assignments go on the back end
reach back out to me and if you want to
call back on the show and we can keep
this conversation going i would love
that we'll talk to you soon and
everybody will be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else buying a
home and my friends who refinance their
homes they tell me it makes them nuts
too i love living in a new home but i
gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to terry
in fort worth hey terry what's up
um hi dr john how are you how are you
i'm good i'm good
how are you hello i'm okay i'm okay got
some stuff going on
lots of stuff going on
sorry okay let's do it what's up
okay i'm calling about my 20 year old
daughter um
she's on the autism spectrum
diagnosed shortly before her sixth
birthday
had lots of therapy in her early
childhood and
everything went great
i mean to the point where her primary
and secondary education
she was able to get through without any
type of medication
uh but the last three years i've seen a
decline
significant decline and
the insurance
at my job it's almost 300 of pay period
just for
health insurance and then she doesn't
um
she's not eligible for
any
type of chip or medicaid because i'm
slightly over that bracket as well and
i'm just at i'm lost because i'm not
sure
how to help her
there's also she dealt with bullying in
school
to an extreme extent
and there was also some abuse
in younger childhood sexual abuse
physical abuse yes
yes sexual and it's it's just a lot i'm
trying to
help her from the grass
with um
try therapy
once in 2019 once in 2020 um
and
the issues were never
brought to light to discuss and so i i'm
i'm at a loss okay i'm at a loss on how
to help my daughter so the first thing
just as a fellow parent i'm sorry this
hurts and you're watching your daughter
somebody that you love and you've
invested your whole life into really
struggling and that hurts for everybody
just as a fellow parent i'm sitting here
with you and i'm sorry that hurts man
um
so
let me ask a couple of just detailed
questions and then we can kind of get
right into it um what kind of
accommodations did she
receive in
middle school and high school especially
um she had um
what was called oh gosh what was the
term
uh gosh it seemed like so long ago where
there was
assistance if she needed it
it wasn't like someone you know
following her throughout the day but if
she needed assistance um
she could get like no taking assistance
or oh yes okay um
now extra time on a test or something
yes exactly and that was needed in
elementary not so much
in
middle school and high school but in
elementary yes she had those uh
resources is she going to school is she
going to college now
she actually just completed her first
year of college very cool and so yeah
was that a struggle
oh yes okay all right oh yes uh the
first semester um
was virtual okay
which was last year i mean last semester
this semester that she just finished she
was on campus um she would share a ride
chair ride would pick her up you know
bring her to the campus and
is he still living at home with you
she is okay she is
and she wants to
have some more independence and
i know that's needed at a certain point
i
just know i need to get her those
resources to help her okay
to navigate yes everything that she is
experiencing and has experienced so
here's um all right so there's a couple
of things here
um
there is
some let me put it this way i've seen
students go to college
um
i'm assuming she's relatively high
functioning right
yeah um yes that takes that term but yes
i know i hate that term too i despise
that term because there are seasons when
i'm low functioning and high functioning
and i think it's a complete uh
it's a it's a nonsensical phrasing but
it's just what we got right now um
the uh
so
i've seen students go to college and
absolutely blossom
in tremendous ways
um even students who would be
generally classified as um like
median functioning like really have a
lot of challenges
and so
the first thing i would do is look at my
university system that my child's a part
of
and sit down with the
ada 504 coordinator the disability
services
and sit down with the counseling center
and
to say here are all of the resources
available to me and i've been and i
can't even tell you how many of those
meetings i've been in um
they are generally extraordinary
and often the other thing happens and so
i painted you a rosy picture often kids
will go to school who've had all kinds
of accommodations and they are on the
spectrum they want to just go finally
jump in and be quote unquote normal like
everybody else
and i always tell students always always
always
do not
stop doing your things your first year
continue with the accommodations if
you're taking meds you just i just want
to stop doing continue doing that
because the transition is so significant
the pace is so much faster there's so
many more inputs coming and for a kid's
uh an autistic child all of that sensory
input is just can be overwhelming and
everybody everywhere all the time it's
just a lot right
so
i would really lean into those
institutional resources
and by the way you're already paying for
all of them
you're paying for all of them and so it
you may have to pay for an um an aba
diagnostic right that will that if you
don't already have one of those you
probably already have one of those
here's the bigger picture that i'm
hearing
and
this may or may i mean you and i have
just met each other like a second ago on
the phone
at some point your daughter's gonna have
to deal with the sexual abuse and the
bullying
yeah and i would plug her into a
therapist on campus with the this this
level of detail
i was sexually abused as a kid
i was autistic and so i was mercilessly
bullied as a child and into middle
school and high school
and i need help healing
so take that type of direct language
what is not helpful for any of us much
less somebody on the spectrum is just
going to a therapist and talking
mindlessly about feelings for day on day
on day on day on day
right it's not helpful i need some new
actions to help my body x y and z okay
absolutely um so be that bold and really
she needs to be that bold because she's
20 and that leads me to my last thing
here
mama at some point you're gonna have to
let this this little girl go
okay and that's super hard and i don't
mean go and stop being um
you know not
not being attuned to her life not making
sure she's going to her appointments
asking about meds not that stuff
but in your mind she's still that
elementary school or middle school girl
that you're trying to take care of
because you love her and you know she's
different and you know people have been
mean to her and hurt her and you'll be
damned if it's gonna happen to get on
your watch
is that right yeah
yeah okay and that's the
that impulse is beautiful
and that impulse is what's going to keep
her from
going to this next level which is
navigating a messy ugly
hard world
with
um
neurological differences not being
neurotypical right
okay
is it i mean tell me if i'm wrong is
that is that true no you're right you're
right okay absolutely
so
if if she was on the phone with me now
how would she describe you
um
loving
uh protective
you said it perfectly working from home
oh beautiful stunning
that was awesome
so she would she would label you
as
protective both in the best and the
worst of ways right yes yes how would
she prefer to get to school can she
drive
no no she's sure right
but can she drive
no she cannot could she drive could she
learn to
um
i guess i'm not the one to teach her
because i shouldn't teach anyone how to
drive but she should
terry you're skirting my question
because you're brilliant from where she
would learn we did say this summer we
would try some driving lessons driving
courses
so
it's time to let this young woman grow
up she make does she do well
academically
yes uh besides the struggles this last
uh semester one a a b and two c's so yes
um for a
given to what she's
going through both environmentally and
neurologically and
if she went through that whole semester
without any accommodations after
receiving them
then that's she did a great job
right yeah and yeah
that's
super impressive you wait till she gets
the help that she needs
and she's gonna shoot through the roof
like on a rocket ship okay
and so here's what here's all all of
this is is
coming down to this
is a intentional graduated plan to begin
to teach her the adult skills and this
is sooner rather than later
teach her the adult skills she needs
to go be successful
and you know what a big part of this is
going to be
you terry
are carrying her on the guilt of the
sexual abuse
and you terry are carrying around the
guilt of the bullying
and you're carrying around the guilt of
her having autism
and i need you to forgive yourself to
set those bricks down and i want you to
go talk to somebody about how to let
this little girl go
but will you do that because you deserve
that terry is that fair
yes
okay
that shame is holding you down and
keeping you from breathing all these
years later you got to set that stuff
down
will you do that
absolutely
okay you hang on the line too i'm gonna
send you a copy of the new book also on
your past change of future
and uh i want you to read through that
book and all that whole book is about
setting bricks down okay thank you so
much and i want you to call a counselor
and man if i'm you today i'm getting on
the phone with the ada office
uh actually i'm gonna sit with my
daughter because she's she is 20. we're
going to talk to her about what we're
doing um it's not great for any college
kid just to show up and find out parents
have been calling unless they're worried
about some significant psychiatric
issues hey we're going to call the ada
office
and we're going to call the uh the
disabilities office and we're going to
call the counseling services and we're
going to take advantage of all these
services that we're paying for at this
university and we're going to lean
heavily into a behavior plan and we're
going to make a list ask your ask that
baby girl of yours who's now 20
ask her
okay i've been on you for a long time
what are some things you'd like to be
doing on your own like driving like
maybe getting her own apartment someday
like some of these other things
and let's come up with a plan to get
there
and then after all that's done your
heart's going to be beating you may even
get teared up
i want you to exhale then i want you to
get online i want you to call a
counselor and say it's time for me to
start getting well too you my sister
deserve that we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right what a show that was a long
one and that was a heavy one and man
that was took me back to grad school on
a few of those and um
a lot of people struggling a lot of
people hurt and a lot of people just
trying to love better
and it's such a good reminder for all of
us
don't stop trying to love better don't
stop trying to heal don't stop trying to
love the people around you whether it's
your kids whether it's your partner who
i'm so grateful so so grateful as you
wrap up today's show of course you knew
we were going to do it
it's the it's the classic whitney
houston i want to dance with somebody
and it goes like this
clock strikes upon the hour and the sun
begins to fade still enough time to
figure out how to chase my blues away
i've done all right until now it's the
light of day that shows me how and when
the night falls loneliness calls we've
all been there
so i want to dance with somebody i want
to feel the heat with somebody yeah i
want to dance with somebody somebody who
loves me
i've been in love and lost my senses
spinning through the town sooner or
later the fever never ends and i wind up
feeling down
i want to dance with somebody don't we
all
and that's what this show's about
dancing with each other we'll see you
soon
coming up on the next episode summer's
coming up and i've been thinking a lot
about the fact that we've always been a
little
sloppy and letting them sleep in really
late one of them would till noon if we
let her you know lay around watch tv
and i'm just kind of i'm wanting to
balance
i love the idea of getting kids up at
six and seven and getting their butts
out to work especially in the summer to
all you people out there like well kids
just gotta suck it up and get out you're
right i know i wish that was the case
but look around our teenagers are
literally falling apart underneath us
how do we honor our 13 year old
daughter's wishes to not take action
against her molester and also do what we
feel is right i'm going to give it to
you straight as an arrow okay over 200
times
someone molests a child
before they're finally caught your 13
year old does not get to drive this you
have to report it full stop